[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero
después de casi 50 años la corte suprema
de eeuu tumbó el derecho al aborto en
este país una decisión histórica y sin
precedentes que ha generado una ola de
controversia en la crónica de historia
de esta semana repasamos como eeuu logró
legalizar el aborto gracias al caso roe
versus wave en 1973 y como prácticamente
desde ese entonces diversos sectores
religiosos y políticos se han opuesto a
este derecho hasta que han conseguido
revertir lo de nuevo al igual que en la
mayoría del planeta el aborto estuvo
prohibido en eeuu durante décadas por
cuestiones religiosas y morales aunque
se practicaba clandestinamente bajo
pésimas condiciones sin embargo no se
puede hablar de la lucha por un aborto
libre hasta la llegada del siglo 20 y
concretamente los años 50 y 60 de ese
siglo para esa época numerosos
colectivos feministas y defensores de
los derechos humanos comenzaron a
organizarse para que el aborto empezara
a ser libre una opción que garanti a la
salud y seguridad de las mujeres estos
movimientos siempre encontraron una
fuerte oposición de la iglesia católica
y protestante y de las instituciones más
conservadoras pero en la década de 1960
casos como el de sheriff in vain una
mujer que se vio obligada a viajar a
suecia para abortar porque su feto
presentaba malformaciones o el de jerry
santoro que falleció tras practicarse un
aborto ilegal en malas condiciones
levantaron conciencias en una parte de
la sociedad que empezó a movilizarse en
favor de este derecho
el propósito es protestar contra las
interferencias de la iglesia en los
derechos de las mujeres cuando les
deniegan el aborto pero también reclamar
la liberación de la mujer aquí ya que
ahora mismo están siendo oprimidas por
una parte de los hombres ya va siendo
hora de que reconozcamos que la opresión
en cualquiera de sus formas es malvada e
incorrecta algunos estados comenzaron a
levantar restricciones de forma parcial
al aborto y solamente unos pocos lo
hicieron de forma total hasta que en
1971 llegó el caso del robo white en el
norma mccorvey una joven de 21 años de
texas que no pudo interrumpir su tercer
embarazo por las estrictas leyes de su
estado presentó una demanda contra el
fiscal del distrito local henry wait
mccord y se presentó al tribunal del
distrito norte de texas bajo el
seudónimo de jane roe y el fallo le dio
la razón tras ello el estado de texas
apeló a la corte suprema que volvió a
resolver la controversia en favor de mas
corbí en 1973 con siete votos a favor y
dos en contra la sentencia fue histórica
por que legislaba que el aborto no podía
ser prohibido durante el primer
trimestre de embarazo ya que eso
atentaba contra el derecho a la
intimidad de la mujer algo que permitía
practicarlo en ese espacio sin que los
estados intervinieran el alto tribunal-
catalogó el derecho a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo como fundamental
y esto hizo que las leyes a nivel
federal cambiaran
para entender su importancia se puede
observar este mapa antes del caso de roe
versus wave en 30 de los 50 estados que
formaban eeuu el aborto era ilegal en
otros 16 estaba condicionado a
determinados casos como violaciones o
peligro de muerte para la madre o el
feto y sólo en cuatro se podía ejercer
libremente la sentencia revirtió por
completo esta situación pero esto no
significó el final de la polémica los
colectivos anti abortos siguieron
manifestándose en contra de este derecho
y luchando para volver a ilegalizar lo
de tres de esta lucha había sectores
ultra religiosos y también miembros del
partido republicano que empezaron a
politizar esta causa haciendo de ella un
tema controversial un ejemplo es el ex
presidente ronald reagan que ganó en
1980 las elecciones presidenciales con
la promesa de revertir el roe versus
wait
no debemos descansar y les prometo que
no descansaré hasta que una enmienda a
la vida humana se convierta en parte de
nuestra constitución
la lucha anti aborto fue tomando fuerza
durante los años siguientes e incluso
logró establecer algunas restricciones
en 1992 lograron eliminar la garantía
del primer trimestre para interrumpir el
embarazo y en 1996 y 1997 el congreso de
mayoría republicana para ese entonces
estuvo cerca de prohibir los abortos de
extracción intacta del feto bill clinton
logró vetar esa decisión durante su
presidencia aunque en 2003 el ex
presidente george w.bush logró aprobar y
ratificar una ley que restringía este
tipo de abortos ya que los sectores más
conservadores lo consideran un parto
parcial
la preocupación moral de la humanidad se
extiende a aquellos niños no nacidos que
son dañados o asesinados en crímenes
contra sus madres y ahora la protección
de la ley federal se extiende también a
esos niños those room es web durante los
años siguientes los estados más
conservadores fueron aplicando
restricciones sucesivas al aborto pero
sin llegar a ilegalizar lo una situación
que se aceleró con la llegada al poder
de donald trump el exmandatario se
mostró como un firme opositor al aborto
y durante su mandato tuvo la potestad de
nombrar a tres jueces nuevos en la corte
suprema- magistrados de un carácter
ultraconservador que han sido
fundamentales para que este 24 de junio
el alto tribunal estadounidense
decidiera tumbar la histórica sentencia
de roe versus wave la decisión de
aplicar el derecho al aborto está ahora
en manos de los estados varios de ellos
ya lo penalizaron y se estima que unos
26 en total podrían y legalizarlo una
situación que afectará a decenas de
miles de mujeres y que es una reversión
de derechos sin precedentes
esta nación con esto concluimos gracias
por compartir y comentar estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]